I've experienced several kinds of
criticism number one when we were on
tour last year there was a threatened
protest the University of Michigan
because we are the radio works for the
State of Israel so there is a growing
sentiment on American campuses which is
anti-israel their talks of boycotts
there's a long anti-israel sentiment and
we picked up a little bit of that in
addition um the extremely articulate
anti-zionist anti-israel intellectual
group views me as a kind of operatic for
the Zionist state so there are
suspicious of me for taking this
position which I have had for seven
years which I do by the way without
compensation I take no fee I do it I
give my feedback to the orchestra so
there is a little bit of pushback on the
other side since bard has the only dual
degree program between an America
university and a Palestinian we have a
cooperation without codes University on
the West Bank for master's degree
program training teachers and honors
college and we're building two high
schools I've been attacked by the
Zionists right for being too cooperative
and with the with the Arab population
and being in favor of a two-state
solution and so the Israeli right
doesn't share my point of view and so
this cooperation reading American
University and a Palestinian has not
earned me some friends on the right so I
been attacked from both sides as a
result of my involvement in Israel but
the the problem is that I would have
liked to see the Jerusalem Symphony
reach out to all of the residents in
Jerusalem including the resident East
Jerusalem but it's very hard to very
polarized situation i'm not a season
State of Israel so I'm there as a
foreigner and as a guest so I try to
stay away from politics as much as
possible so by and large we've had a
good luck but there's been some some
criticism not as much as as I might have
expected
no I go music convenience for peace it
is an instrument that can be a common
ground you know there's a lot of talk
about music being a universal language
but it is in other words it's
fascinating to see different cultures
want to play the same repertoire on the
same music a Chinese Orchestra Japanese
Orchestra Venezuelan Orchestra
Vietnamese there three classical
orchestras in Hanoi so it is probably
compatible with multiple identities you
can be a nationalist Chinese
nationalists and love Beethoven but you
can also be a Nazi and love data when
you can be a freedom fighter
anti-fascist and love Beethoven so
everybody owns it and nobody owns
classical music it's a common ground but
it is not itself a builder of peace one
would hope that our sense of being
musical that your musical that I'm
musical and we both enjoy music we might
enjoy the same music would lead us to
respect each other but that hasn't
happened with language you know we've
killed people who speak the same
language we do for other reasons there's
color of the skin was different their
religion was different their political
views were different their gender was
different their sexual preference was
different but they speak the same
language somehow the fact that you and I
speak the same language is not enough
for me in the larger sense to respect
the sanctity of your own life so I'm
going to go to war against you even
though we speak the same language
nominally so music is much the same
thing it's very little illusion to think
that it is an instrument of peace